now people have gotten really mad and I
want you to hear me I understand this we
have a lot of people who watch who are
not conservative and we appreciate our
libertarians who are anti social justice
warrior who are anti-authoritarian but
are not right-wing and I appreciate you
and I definitely want you to stay here
and have a dialogue but I'm not going to
pander to you like a lot of other people
out there I know there are winning
issues like guns and free speech and
feminism and we can talk about that and
I know you get really mad when I do the
Bernie Sanders thing but you need to
understand something
economic authoritarianism is still
authoritarianism I wrote about this that
Hitler what do we hear about Hitler he
was super right wing right wing Nazi
stands for National Socialist German
Workers Party okay
so put that in your back pocket now let
me get to something people will say I
know what you're going to say National
Socialism not democratic socialism like
Bernie Sanders there's a huge one as
fascism right-wing one is not they're
both socialism democratic socialism
always becomes national nationalistic
socialism by definition it has to why
okay the United States is not a
democracy you throw around the term
democratic as though it's it's noble no
we're a constitutional representative
republic why that's important to know
it's important to know we're not a
democracy
that's because democracy is mob rule the
reason the United States was framed as a
constitutional representative Republic
is to make sure that the rights of the
minority are still protected from the
majority otherwise the majority can just
vote in screw the minority no more
liberal you should be on board with that
democracy by definition would inherently
bad be bad for minorities so am I saying
Bernie Sanders is like Hitler
no but the ideology is the ideology that
lends itself toward authoritarianism and
fascism because of an increased
expansion of the state Hitler promised
employment for all of course was a self
about socialist innovative Public Works
schemes gave workers increased benefits
he increased jobs by increasing the
state not allowing wages to rise with
prices because he wanted people working
for the government he ensured everyone
had a job big education free daycare you
had basically an entire generation who
were raised by the state nationalized
health care up to an eighty percent tax
gun control of course implemented gun
control abortion was radically
pro-abortion
blaming on the one percent back then the
one percent were Jews none of these
things are right-wing none of these
things are libertarian or conservative
so let's get to if you go policy for
Policy there's nothing about them that's
right when you're conservative other
than the fact that you're going to try
and attribute racism to conservatism
because that's what you've been taught
to do by your college professor now why
is this so important going back to
representative government well Hitler
used the idea of democracy mob rule to
infringe on the rights of the minority
the majority Germans Germans its
democratic and it's nationalistic they
believe Germany was for free that for
the true Germans not for the Jews
democracy nationalism either way mob
rule the Nationalists win that's the
whole point
and they infringe on the rights of
minorities now I want you to take that
and change it for one second take Jews
switch it to the wealthy because the
Jews were 1% is I have these numbers
here Jews and Germany made up less than
1% they they use that a lot the 1%
rhetoric change Germans to working-class
you have an economic version of exactly
the same thing am I saying the
working-class wants to halt millionaires
small business owners into gas chambers
no what I'm saying is that's what
democratic socialism is mob rule mob
rule Germans against the Jews minorities
lose their rights mob rule Bernie
Sanders mob rule democratic socialism as
opposed to National Socialism
mob rule working-class takes the rights
of the wealthy in an economic way while
simultaneously just like Hitler
expanding the state free-school bigger
government cracking down on businesses
so more people go to public school raise
their kids in public daycare work for
the government and you
the power from the private sector
putting it to the government
here's the deal I don't have that much
faith in government the idea that Hitler
was right-wing know he was a very very
emphatic liberal big government
socialist undeniable the Valentine's
tiny clusters and amazing or ill grouped
in electronic controls where nothing
Diwali is I like this video subscribe by
clicking my face or the button above or
you oh it's you why don't you have a
girlfriend yet